did you learn calculus and then get GA
or did you cheat and get the a like it's
like you know the answer to that
question yeah like the a isn't the goal
it's the representation of your
knowledge and your mastery
this is Michael Seibel with Dalton
Caldwell today we're going to talk about
setting goals
more specifically all of the pitfalls
involved in setting or trying to
accomplish goals that startup Founders
we work with tend to fall for
Dalton why don't you set this one up
yeah you know when we were talking about
it this morning the the phrase or the
meme that came to mind was the one uh
play stupid games Win stupid prizes
you know and again
what I think it means in this context is
if if you set goals or if you start
playing one specific game that is silly
to begin with OR that ha it's like
clearly a bad call
um yeah the prizes the implications of
that the things that you win are going
to be equally silly or nonsensical or
non-productive okay and so we see a lot
of people
who set goals to in effect play play
kind of stupid games let's talk about
the stupid games and then we'll talk
about the stupid prizes at the end those
are those are maybe even more fun so you
know I think it's it makes sense to
split this up into mistakes that people
make setting goals and then mistakes
people make trying to accomplish these
goals so I would say like the first one
um and maybe I'll start with the
simplest is when people set goals that
are so aggressive they aren't
motivational
and and they're basically missing the
understanding of what the purpose of
setting a goal is right like you want to
motivate yourself to act smarter faster
more intelligently than you would
otherwise
and oftentimes people are setting goals
that are too aggressive
um because they're motivated by fear you
know NYC we see this all the time
and what's an example of a too
aggressive goal like what do you think I
can give you an example of what do you
do yeah you know I'll see a YC founder
who comes into YC just starting to build
their product
and they tell me by demo day we want to
have you know 30k in mrr
and we want to do that because some Alum
told us that like that's how much MRI
you need in order to raise money on demo
day and it's just like
how many errors can be said in three
sentences you know is is my thought
what's an example comes in your mind my
mom example is someone
that believes once they launch a product
it will immediately succeed and take off
and so it's like we're going to spend
three months building this app we're
going to put it in the App Store we're
going to launch
and then we're going to get a hundred
thousand Dau yeah yeah and it's yeah
like two minutes
yeah it's always the plan is they're
gonna put it out and then it's gonna
immediately take off
those are always the goals
that um that are rough and what's funny
is we're always like why do you launch
sooner so you have more time to make it
grow after it launches and like no no no
we're gonna spend all the time making it
good and so they want to go it's gonna
immediately take off top of the App
Store 100
why would we launch something bad then
it won't take off Dalton Jesus yeah we
we we're going to talk to some
influencers you know we're gonna do a
social media launch we've got it all
lined up we have a wait list so yeah top
of the charts definitely
game on so um
both examples of being too aggressive
um the next one that comes up a lot is
uh fake metrics
um and we've talked about this a little
bit but you know for companies who
charge their customers money
somehow creating a goal incremented in
something that's not money
um hey my product costs ten dollars a
month but I'm measuring registered users
I want to hit you know a thousand
registered users and it's like
that's weird like hell if users is going
to be the metric like why wouldn't it be
active users right like just like if
we're going to be in that world well
that's too hard Michael that's why it's
not fair but if we're charging them why
wouldn't it be the amount of money we
make like that seems even simpler
um but I think you've seen a wide
variety of fake metrics that goes way
further than users right yeah okay
counting hits on your website that's an
oldie but a goodie yeah yeah um Counting
downloads but not registrations is a
good one yeah
um Counting users as people
that started the registration process
and didn't finish it
counting users as people that downloaded
your product opened it closed it after
five seconds and never opened it again
as users yes yes
uh we've heard that one um just
basically like a thousand and one
different ways to avoid
the actual
um
meaning of the metric which is to
capture if it's working or not
it's like every every which way people
are so creative at finding ways to like
not actually measure the thing that they
know they're supposed to be measuring
and
cells are default to fool like investors
or authority you know what I'm saying
like it's hard for me to tell when
someone is practicing self-deception
that like number of downloads is the
right metric or if they think that no
one else realizes that that's obviously
like no one can tell what they're trying
to do we can tell and honestly it's
probably both right it's probably a
combination of both right like
um okay so here's another one that I see
a lot especially with fundraising stupid
comparatives So like um in 2021 tiger
gave this company a hundred million
dollar funding when they accomplished
blank
500 000 of ARR therefore
we will be able to raise a hundred
million dollars of funding when we
accomplish 500 000 error right Michael
right like there's no difference between
you know summer 2022 and summer 2021
well that's how it works right is
investors what they do is they just um
are always consistent and they always
make the same decisions and it's easy
for you to tell reading the TechCrunch
announcement why the investor made the
investment right it's clear like I read
the article
um you know this VC invested in this
company were kind of like that company
in some superficial ways
it's in the bag we got it
and then the other one that I love about
it is like no Michael like that round
was announced last week that just
happened and it's like sorry but lots of
things are allowanced way after they
happen
way way after and so again what I think
what we're saying about what's the
stupid goal in this case
playing the stupid game here is trying
to create superficial resemblance to
other things
yes as opposed to Deep
the thing is working in or maybe there's
a deeper analog to the other thing but
if you're just focusing on the very
surface level stuff
yeah you're that is not a smart game to
be playing one other example maybe an
old one we talked about in the past you
know with Facebook where you might be
able to argue well they raise money when
they only had a small number of users
right and then you completely punt on
the fact that like
that small number of users were 95
percent two hour a day Facebook users
yes so the engagement was like
incredible yeah if you can replicate
Facebook's engagement
then you've got something versus
replicating I don't know it's for
college kids or I don't know people have
very superficial
um stuff there oh God you brought up one
um on our list about sandbagging let's
talk about sandbagging a little bit Yeah
so sandbagging I don't know how much
people are used to that term
um I think it's
think I'm it's a golf term but
sandbagging is basically where you set
goals that are intentionally way easy to
hit
with the goal of blowing them out of the
water right so say you know you can
accomplish something in one week the
sandbag version of the goal is to give
yourself a month and then when you go
around and you hit the goal you like
look like a genius and what's funny
is when you are working for the man when
you are working at a company like office
space you know you're in a cube Farm
somewhere
um it makes sense to sand bad goals and
that's actually great career advice I
suppose is that you you know you set
really you convince people that
something's really hard to do and then
you exceed their expectations what a
great way to get promoted or whatever of
course however there's a problem if
you're used to doing that and that's how
you think all things should work when
you start working for yourself when you
were Your Own Boss you are screwing
yourself and what may be a good strategy
to like rest invest working at Google or
Facebook and to just do as little work
as possible by sandbagging goals and
working three hours a week or whatever
people do when you're the boss
do you see how that's like not great
well and you better believe that big
company you work for didn't have that
culture when it was starting yeah the
founders of that company were not doing
that no all right let's talk about
accomplishing goals so okay let's say I
set a good goal right I I'm a
post-launch B2B SAS company with a
couple users and I am setting a goal of
getting my first 10 paying users right
great like we're in the right ballpark
let's hear about how people screw
up accomplishing goals and somehow kind
of still play the stupid game right out
of the gate it's the way that you
accomplished it is something that you
know in your heart is not
like
how what's the word I want to use kosher
I don't know what would you what word
would you use it Michael like
um
I like using the word cheating like you
know it's like
you're taking a calculus test
did you learn calculus and then get d a
or did you cheat and get the a like it's
like you know the answer to that
question yeah like the a isn't the goal
it's the representation of your
knowledge and your mastery
if you didn't
learn something when accomplishing the
goal
maybe you didn't accomplish the goal you
know you can fool investors you can full
co-found you can fool please yeah yeah
people
are very trusting and so I think the way
the mistake people make is they think
that because they fooled people in a
short term
they're like yeah you know what I
actually did was I got my friends and
family to do blah blah or what I act you
know there's like something where you're
like yeah this didn't we cheated but no
one else seems to be aware of us you're
like well I guess
I guess this worked I guess this is how
this goes
so um another way that people screw up
the accomplishing goals is not
understanding how to take the L
okay maybe you set the wrong goal
and instead of um
realizing that
and setting a new goal
you cheat or do one of these other
tactics to try to accomplish it because
you feel as though not accomplishing
your goal is a failure and of itself man
I find Founders screw this up
constantly it's like
you don't have to assume you're going to
be good at setting goals like you can
give yourself some slack assume you're
going to be bad at it and like you can
adjust over time you can set better
goals over time you cannot accomplish
your goals and learn from it
um there isn't this you know sometimes
NYC I think people feel this like oh
we're grading them on whether they
accomplish their goals and it's like
first of all we're not grading we're not
your teacher we're not your boss and
second of all like your job is to work
on the hardest problem in your company
like that like if you've made progress
on the hardest problems in your company
you're doing well
that's the that's the whole gist of this
it's not like oh did you like
release that feature when you said you
were going to you know that No One's
Gonna use
foreign
oh man and then you talk about excuses a
lot how do people screw that up when
they don't accomplish their goal I just
notice a lot that when folks set goals
and they're not able to hit them that's
okay but when folks are in a position
where they really think it's important
to make a lot of excuses on why it's not
their fault and with everyone else's
fault and they just have this like inner
desire
to like tell me all the excuses I think
that's not helpful in that like again
I'm not the bot like I don't care okay
you didn't hear a goal great let's move
on like like it's like they want
Redemption
and so I just think that it's good
if something doesn't work to accept it
to acknowledge to look at it but realize
you're the boss of yourself and you
should just not feel a need to make a
million excuses or have like like create
this long narrative where you're the
victim and everyone else it's not your
fault and your heart was in the right
place and you did everything right but
everyone else was wrong this is usually
stuff about sales cycle well you know
the sales cycle is just long like this
is just too hard and it's just when
people do this
my message to him is like hey that's
fine I'm not saying your excuse is wrong
but like why are you spending all this
energy trying to plead a case like
you're in court
that the thing didn't work as opposed to
like well move on and make something
that does work how about that
spend energy
in a positive proactive Direction then
weaving The Narrative of yourself is the
person who did great but you're
misunderstood by the universe this is an
internal tool like this is a tool for
you to use your help yourself this is
not
a tool for you to please someone else
like that that's kind of irrelevant
so let's do the takeaway here you know
you set this up with play stupid games
Win stupid prizes
um let's talk about some of the stupid
prizes that we see companies with where
do you want to start here the last thing
is if you sent that goal
if you start playing a silly game
and we see lots of people win at the
game and so one of the game one of the
stupid games sometimes people play is
just how much money can I raise the more
money I raise the better my goal is most
dollars raised and the bigger that
number is the better I am so you're
playing the game you won the game
congratulations what's the prize you win
Michael what's the stupid prize if you
play the raids as much as you can game
often you lose control of your company
so like when you confront the challenges
suddenly you know your board can fire
you
often you find yourself burning tons of
money because a lot of people who gave
you money expect you to spend it
um oftentimes you have the wrong people
on your team
you have a bunch of people who think
you've made it who think that this is
you know the next Google when in reality
it's it's it it's not
um
and then last
you might have to change what you're
working on or change the problem or
pivot in some significant way but now
they're all of these people and all this
money and all this momentum going down a
Direction that's driving a company off
the cliff
and that pivot becomes 10 times harder
or or damn near impossible oftentimes
um but you did win the fundraising game
yeah it's like congratulations so
congratulations
here's your prize you have a messed up
company that shouldn't have raised all
the money and you've got to dig yourself
out of a disaster and everyone's mad at
you here you go you won the prize have
fun
the next fun one is
I want to feel like someone running a
big company I want to have 50 employees
I want to have 100 employees I want to
have 500 employees I want to be a boss
of a live number of employees I want a
real big team I want to move real fast
that's my game yeah it's always about
moving fast that's the lies like if we
had this we could finally move as fast
as like uh you know we could finally
build all the things that I want us to
build so what's the stupid prize on that
one Dalton now you wake up one day and
you look at the spreadsheet of your burn
and you you look at all the people that
work at your company and you're like oh
no
and guess what it's now your problem
because now you might have to do a
layoff you might have to let people go
you might mess up people's lives that
believed in you you might mess up that
or have moral issues there it's like the
worst thing ever to over hire and have
to deal with it and if you talk to
someone that's had to deal with this
this is usually one of the more the
biggest failures if you look at your
life I know that's how I feel like
personally is the biggest failures I've
ever had were definitely having to let
people go that I shouldn't have hired so
congratulations you win the prize you
hired a bunch of people you're a big
important person
now you're responsible for all of this
yes
um here's the other one
I love this one
um Dalton I need an executive team it's
it's time for my company to become a
real serious company and to do that I
need an executive team
and so I'm going to spend the next year
recruiting the executive team like it's
time I'm I'm ready to grow up Dalton I'm
ready to grow up
what do you think about this one how
many great Executives have we
encountered over the years I mean look I
think if all you do is consume like VC
content you're this is some an idea that
gets introduced into your brain and I
think maybe there is a time where this
is a good answer
but it's like so much of the the VC
content is aimed at late stage Founders
which is pretty weird
um it's like putting out content that's
like you know
how to care for your um
your Ferrari or something like again I
don't really know who a lot of this is
the majority of the people the consume
it or like two or three person startups
and if you if all of your advice is like
hire an executive team when you have
like a three-person pre-pmf startup like
oh man like you can get someone to leave
you can get someone with a title to
leave Google or Facebook or somewhere
really impressive and you think you're
like a big winner that you got someone
from this cool company to join your
company
but then you wake up and you're like wow
what did I do like like what usually
happens is they either
are even though they join your startup
because they're they weren't doing well
I'm trying to think of a nice way to say
it either there's a reason they joined
your startup and left Google
or they had expectations that you were
farther along or more successful than
you actually are and they get very upset
with you when they realize that your
startup sucks
tricky
all right the next one the next gift
that you receive when you play a stupid
game we've touched on this a little bit
is
I'm now burning tons of money because I
just scaled negative margins you know I
had something that wasn't working in
this city and I expanded that thing to
30 other cities and now it's not working
at a massive scale
and I did it because my investors told
me to
and now those investors aren't taking my
phone call and this is like so hard
because I think people don't realize
that either
some stage of investors or at some point
in your company someone's gonna pull out
your finances and do basic arithmetic
and ask themselves is this real
and like eventually you will be judged
based on like is this real and
sustainable
and if it's not like you know hey
sometimes you even get post IPO but like
at some point
those people are having a bad time we're
not going to name any names
it's not being post IPO and then having
your stock with 95 of its value
I don't think not fun those people are
having a good they played a game and
here's like the prize they have is um
is having a rough time so I definitely
feel as though Founders make this
mistake of like if I raise the last
round by massively scaling my negative
margins I'll be able to raise the next
round and
that luck runs out at some point
um you know the next topic is on you
know acquiring companies and I think
that um
this comes in a number of flavors one is
once again we're finally grown up we can
make our first acquisition or like we
want to get good at this acquisition
thing so we gotta start doing it there's
a lot of talent out there Michael and
some really talented failing startups
would love to be able to be acquired by
us and this will help us grow faster so
we're gonna we're gonna acquire them and
by the way that doesn't mean that like
acquiring companies is bad it it just
often means the folks who are thinking
about it in startup land tend to be
thinking about it too early is this like
another example of like taking later
stage advice too early
when like the advice you should be
taking is make your core business work
like just make it through pmf if you
don't have product Market fit yourself
or probably
it's probably not a great idea you're
laughing but people are probably like
wait really yeah really
you know I I Dalton I uh you're right I
am laughing because that's like that's
an inconceivable Concept in my mind
you're like oh we're pre-product Market
fit we should definitely be spinning up
Court Dev
um here's another one that's in the news
more and more lately
um defrauding your customers selling
your customers something and telling
them it's one thing and
you know it's not that thing
and your customers lose money or your
customers
are in some way extremely harmed what's
the prize for doing that Dalton
um no joke it seems like there's people
going to jail and getting arrested and
people whose actual lives are now
irreparably harmed by the games that
they were playing to get growth or to
get money
and um yeah they're gonna spend you know
best case scenario is spending years and
years and years in court and in the
court system and just having your life
changed like this isn't making a mistake
we want to be clear here like your state
of mind is is extremely important here
this is like knowingly pursuing a
strategy
that you know is harming your users like
and and and
um
I think what's tricky is that oftentimes
people don't think this is happening I
think sometimes people forget
that they're not playing a game and I
think especially in covet land I don't
know like one of my explanations is if
you spend all day
on Twitter and Discord and everything's
a game and everything to joke and
everything's silly you can kind of I
just have noticed some folks lose
themselves and not realize that the
numbers in the spreadsheet are real
dollars and I don't know it's like we're
not playing Monopoly we're not playing
Sellers of Catan and I think that this
the the the prize that you win is the
knock on the door
um from the police
and that's when you're like oh wow this
is this was real life and the last one
on our list
um playing the game of using your
position as a startup founder to become
an amazing investor
and and I think this one's like really
tricky because
for one thing you definitely see a lot
of famous startup Founders have written
kind of Angel and checks into companies
that that tend to do well and so I think
sometimes people confuse that
for oh I should be spending a
significant amount of my time looking
around and trying to be an angel
investor instead of making my company
work and I think that what if I can try
to explain to you what's actually
happening
when you're a good founder oftentimes
you know other good people and the
opportunity you have to give them money
requires almost no time or effort
and so you just and like if you're a
good founder oftentimes people are are
offering you
to Deals and so like you know you're
spending five minutes saying yes this is
an Obviously good thing I use it or this
is my friend I want to support them and
the amount of time and effort you're
spending writing these Angel checks is
basically nil like you know I remember
when I was uh starting social cam I
emailed Brian chesky saying do you want
Angel invest he was like sure
that's it like that was like that was
the entire time that he spent probably
less than 15 seconds
um
I think people don't see this so they
think oh
I need to copy what I see investors on
Twitter doing I need to go Network I
need to go meet Founders and advise them
and do office hours and like all these
things and it's like uh like classic
example of cargo culting right like not
really understanding what's going on the
stupid game you're playing is the status
game like if you play status games where
what you want to do is level up you want
to
put angel investor in your Twitter bio
or something okay you're playing a
status game fair enough the prizes that
you win playing the game is
congratulations
now a bunch of your money is tied up in
illiquid Investments that may or may not
show up so now maybe you're like
financially strapped maybe you're
worried about other stuff you're worried
about your startup so maybe you're
performing worse because your money is
tied up somewhere
you have spent a bunch of time and stuff
you've totally pissed off your employees
whether or not they would say it to your
face
that is not a great way to win Awards
with your team yep you're seenster
congratulations
yeah
so I think to wrap this up right
sometimes Founders don't think enough
about the bad consequences of the games
they're playing
and once they really do the whole logic
tree down to the end they'll realize
that maybe
it's not worth playing those games and
you might as well just build a good
business
and even if that's a tricky message for
you to internalize
think about what you're teaching your
team if you're making these mistakes
right like they will copy what you're
doing because you define success in your
company and so even if you're like oh
for me this is cool right like a perfect
example if if becoming a status seeking
angel investor is like what seems cool
in your company people in your company
can start trying to do it instead of
doing their work and so if they see you
make sure
yeah people in the company start doing
it they like it's kind of like a little
bit you know we're both parents it's
kind of like hey like if you don't want
your kid to be a screw-up you don't do
screw up [ __ ] in front of them like it's
like a pretty simple like like
one-to-one here like
um and on the flip side to kind of end
with a positive note some of our best
companies get so good
at goal setting and accomplishing goals
that they
they move faster than we would ever
imagine possible like they are just
machines at doing this well and
I would argue that most people don't
start doing this well most people who
focus on setting goals and accomplishing
them get better at it over time but man
the rate of improvement is sometimes
shocking
you know sometimes they're Founders who
are kind of fooling themselves who are
thinking like hey I'm smart so I can
Coast on this stuff it's like
man outliers are smart and great
executors and great trainers right like
they have multiple things they're great
at they don't sandbag themselves
[Music]
foreign
I think we're good I think it's well set
thanks man awesome talk to you later
[Music]
[Music]